The oceans play a huge role
in really every
elemental cycle.
They have a global impact
on the workings
of the Earth really
and so we are focusing
on one aspect of that,
that we know relatively
little about.
How do microbes work together
to fix carbon,
to transfer carbon
amongst themselves?
Where does that carbon go?
How quickly does that carbon turnover?
And so it's important and we'd like to put
all of these data together, think about what
we already know now about the carbon cycle
and see how this new information might change
how we think about it, what we predict from
it.
The particular research area that we've chosen
is an area that has been poorly studied in
the past due to analytical challenges that
we feel now are ready to be applied to this
question.
It's not just how climate change affects the
microbes, but really then how microbes further
affect the climate in response to those changes.
Well, one of the things we've already learned
in our workshop so far is bringing together
people of really diverse backgrounds allows
us access to novel perspectives and different
fields that could be helpful.
Certainly we think that a better understanding
of this system will give us a really powerful,
predictive knowledge about what will happen
in a changing climate.
So the methods are there now, the interest
is there and I think it wasn't possible 10
years ago to say this but it is now.
[Music]